[Music]
on this saturday night
football fever
the canadian fans taking in the
beautiful game
the vaccine push in canada's largest
city the easier we can make it
i think the better for for the health of
our city as ontario gets ready for a new
phase of reopening
the new chief of the assembly of first
nations addresses
allegations of bullying i really am
committed to
creating a healthy safe
workplace one-on-one with roseanne
archibald
and the apprentice a lot of our culture
was taken
so i want to introduce that back into
like the world
his plan for indigenous cuisine
global national with robin gill
good evening and thank you for joining
us you don't have to be in europe to
feel football fever although i'm sure
many of us want to be fans right around
the world in canada too
are getting pumped up as england
prepares to take on italy in sunday's
final of the european championships
it's the second most prestigious
tournament in international football
and if england wins it will be the
country's first major victory since
winning the 1966
world cup but as mike delay reports no
matter which team you're rooting for
it'll be a match to remember
life is good on italy's world famous
shoreline
but is anybody relaxing not until monday
or after italy meets england in the euro
cup final
we're putting up a big tv on the beach
but were nervous
says this resort owner it's no different
in london where football has knocked the
royals off the front page
of every newspaper i'm nervous yeah
it's just if we win i don't know what'll
happen if we lose
then it's the same way but i don't know
in my lifetime even i never thought i'd
see a final to say these two football
mad nations are obsessing over this
match
would undersell it
england has its song as well as the
animal kingdom on its side
a siberian tiger meerkats a parrot and a
pig
all picked england to win and that can't
be a coincidence
but the azuri as the italian team is
known as the eu's chief executive
rooting for them
even if it is a casual nod to brexit her
heart is with the squadra atsura
so she will be supporting italy on
sunday allegiances aside
this is going to be the biggest single
event to take place
since the beginning of the pandemic
wembley stadium will have
limited capacity but even so sixty
thousand fans will be in attendance
back home in canada you can't drive
around any major city
without seeing flags in montreal where
coveted rules have been relaxed
bars and restaurants have been dreaming
of an event like this
to give a much needed boost to business
just like it did in toronto earlier this
week during the semifinals
i don't think you have to be a soccer
supporter to enjoy the euro 2020
championship
i think you just need to be somebody who
wants to take in life again
who wants to be entertained who wants to
enjoy a live sporting event
so it's england versus italy the three
lions in the missouri
but forget about bragging rights this is
about a return to normalcy
microlight global news toronto
there's a massive sporting rivalry
between england and italy
the uk may have home advantage for the
final but italy has the historical edge
with 10 wins in their 28 matches played
the first was friendly in rome back in
1933 that ended in a draw
the last time england beat italy was in
1997
at wembley during a world cup qualifier
for france 98
but italy hasn't won the european
championship since way back
in 1968 and given it's the first time
england has reached the final there's a
lot to play for
toronto is fighting the pandemic in a
new way this weekend
the city is rolling out more than a
dozen pop-up clinics in areas with low
vaccination rates
as morgan campbell explains organizers
hope bringing the vaccine closer to
where people live
will encourage more people to get the
shot
mona malcolm has spent weeks trying to
coordinate a second covit 19 vaccine for
her 81 year old mother
who received her first dose in may every
day i searched vaccine hunters for
somewhere that's close enough for her to
go to because her mother doesn't drive
getting to a mass vaccination site has
been
an issue i just found this this morning
for one week only toronto is rolling out
20 pop-up clinics in the northwest part
of the city
in an effort to increase vaccine uptake
across neighborhoods with low
vaccination rates
to make them easily accessible the
clinics are located
in and near buildings where residents
live intuitively it makes sense that
we'll be able to get higher vaccination
rates
so the easier we can make it i think the
better for
for the health of our city according to
city data
78 percent of eligible toronto residents
have received at least one covit 19
vaccine
about 56 percent are fully vaccinated
meanwhile in scarborough where 16 of the
17
postal codes were designated covid19
hotspots
the community has managed to reach
vaccination rates that are nearly
unparalleled in the province with nearly
half a million doses administered
by the health network it was a
multi-prong approach we knew we had to
get into the community we had the
pop-ups
we have congregate settings we we
developed a community engagement group
and we targeted our faith-based leaders
and we brought the vaccine
to where our residents were this is
exactly what toronto is hoping to
achieve in
its northeast where vaccination rates
for first and second doses
are reach about 20 percent lower than
the city's
overall figures service is very good
there is no crowded talk about like
hour and a half i just live nearby so
it's really good that they held it here
the city says it will be studying
results of the vaccine push in the
northwest with a plan to roll out
similar strategies
in other toronto neighborhoods to get
immunization numbers
up and keep covid infections down
morgan campbell global news toronto as
more coven 19 restrictions lift
hospitals are starting to tackle the
surgical backlog that was made worse by
the pandemic
and with more operations comes the
sudden need
for more blood but donations are down
and as jamie morocco explains
canadian blood services is appealing to
canadians to give
[Music]
after months of surgical delays due to
covet 19
dr sav braar says his toronto or is busy
again
we're able to ramp up quite
significantly
in ontario there's an estimated backlog
of four hundred thousand surgeries
across the country the number jumps
upwards of seven hundred thousand
a sudden surgical increase to tackle
these numbers is highlighting another
critical issue
the demand for blood products has
increased above pre-kobit 19
levels canadian blood services says it
needs over 23
thousand blood donors by july 31st to
fill the gap
instead over the last two weeks
donations have dropped resulting in a
loss of 10 percent of the supply needed
this month
very often it's life or death for shammi
rispoli who suffered a postpartum
complication after giving birth to her
baby boy
it was they had said that i had lost
more than half my blood
and had i lost another handful of units
that could have been fatal not receiving
her transfusion she says
is unimaginable back in toronto dr braar
says a blood shortage is not something
he is seeing currently
but the potential is worrisome this is
something that
would be catastrophic if were to come to
pass
highlighting the short time frame to
fill the need canadian blood services
says because of covid watkins are still
not allowed at donor clinics
instead anybody hoping to give blood
will have to pre-book a time slot
jamie morocco global news toronto the
lights are back on in parts of the
maritimes after post-tropical storm elsa
drenched the region and knocked out
power to thousands of homes
the storm dumped heavy rain and whipped
up high winds along the east coast of
both canada and the united states
it made landfall in florida earlier this
week as that region cleans up
and dries out people living in the west
are dealing with a blast of blistering
heat
jennifer johnson reports on the weather
extremes across the continent
elsa transitioned from a tropical storm
to a post-tropical cyclone
as it crossed into the gulf of maine the
storm brought high winds and dropped
massive amounts of rain along the east
coast
rough surf advisories closed beaches and
ferry services
subways flooded in new york heavy rains
even caused a mudslide shutting down a
rail line in connecticut
i'm not an alarmist but i do know that
climate change is not an abstraction
climate change or seeing it real
by the way the hurricane season hasn't
even begun yet
flash flooding forced multiple water
rescues drivers say roads were
treacherous
i was white knuckling it like almost the
whole way like
wipers on high on america's west coast a
completely different story
drought conditions from no rain just
blistering heat
feels like i'm walking into an oven when
i walk outside experts say this is
becoming the new normal for places like
california
and they say climate change is to blame
the heat waves will be longer
they'll be more intense they'll be more
frequent
it doesn't mean that all heat waves will
be as extreme as this one
but we will be seeing more heat waves
not welcome news for restaurants trying
to recover this summer from last year
when the pandemic shut them down it's
gross
it's way too hot here it's way too hot
we're trying to get reservations to eat
and everything's outdoors and
not doing it according to the national
oceanic and atmospheric administration
the 10 warmest years on record globally
have all occurred since 2005.
if we don't change things it's going to
be
unfortunate for humanity californians
will be sweating it out for a few more
days
the national weather service has issued
an excessive heat warning for much of
the state
through monday night jennifer johnson
global news
washington a confederate statue that was
the focus of a white supremacist rally
in 2017
has been removed
[Applause]
there were cheers when the statue of
general robert e lee was taken down in
charlottesville
virginia during the american civil war
lee fought for the confederates to
protect slavery
four years ago there were plans to
remove it it turned deadly when a
self-described neo-nazi drove a car into
a crowd of counter-demonstrators
killing a peaceful protester another
statue of general thomas stonewall
jackson
has also been removed still ahead the
new assembly of first nations chief
roseanne archibald talks about her
100-day action plan
roseanne archibald is the new national
chief of the assembly of first nations
the first woman to hold this position
vfn is the largest indigenous
organization in canada and advocates on
behalf of 634
first nations but the just newly elected
archibald is having to deal with
controversy within her own organization
she joins us now from ontario can you
first of all address the allegations of
bullying and harassment leveled against
you
it is a confidential report so i'm not
able
to address it in any way and the fact
that the media keeps bringing it up
uh is really to me speaks to
um the difficulty of being the first
woman
uh national chief or being the first
woman in a high profile position like
this that people are choosing to
focus on something negative rather than
the fact that this is a really uplifting
experience for many women across this
country
has this hurt your leadership though at
all
i don't feel like that at all you know
i'm being asked to comment on something
i'm not able to comment on
and it's almost like certain media want
me to
have conversations that are sensitive
and related to human resources
in the public and that's not how you
deal with people that's not how you deal
with human resources
in any organization so i i do want to
just say that i really
am committed to creating a healthy
safe workplace and that's always been my
commitment i've done that wherever i've
gone and
it will be the same at the afn okay
let's talk about your leadership and
your 100-day action plan
one of your first priorities is
recovering what is believed to be the
remains of children on the grounds of
former residential schools
have you talked to the federal
government and the various first nations
groups
on how you're going to accomplish this
yes
the prime minister did call me and he
actually called me to congratulate
me and i was very grateful for that at
the same time you know it's my
opportunity to talk to him one-on-one
so it was one of the first things i
brought up with him i said you know we
require resources to examine
every residential school across this
country a former residential school i
should say
to look for our children these are
crimes against
children they're crimes against humanity
but reparations is just
it's more than just about the amounts
that have been
given through the class action lawsuit
to
survivors of residential school you know
our whole
communities all of our communities our
whole nations
have been affected negatively by
colonialism
particularly residential schools and
there has to be reparations for that
and what that would look like really is
determined by each region
talking about their own experiences and
what they see as the path forward
are you confident though that the
federal government will come up with
funding for this
you know we just are at the tail end of
a pandemic
and the federal government pulled out i
believe over
250 billion dollars to respond to the
pandemic
and so i'm sure that they can actually
access
funds for something that's really
important not only to first nations for
healing but for
all canadians to begin to heal this part
of our
very very tragic history together chief
rosen archibald thank you for your time
thank you still ahead a canadian
airlines efforts to make a travel
comeback
eight people have been arrested in
bangladesh in connection with a deadly
factory fire
firefighters are still putting out hot
spots from thursday's massive fire
at least 52 people were killed but that
number may rise
many workers were trapped inside the
building because the main door
was illegally locked relatives of the
missing are providing dna samples to
help identify the victims
the cause of the fire is under
investigation bangladesh has a history
of deadly industrial disasters
the wife of haiti's assassinated
president is speaking out for the first
time
since his death
[Music]
in a message posted on facebook martinez
says she's alive and doing well
moise is currently being treated in
miami for injuries she suffered in the
attack
haitian police say 28 men burst into the
couple's home on wednesday
shooting and killing president jovenel
moise
so far more than a dozen men most of
them colombian
have been arrested the president's
assassination has plunged haiti
further into turmoil yesterday hundreds
of haitians gathered outside the
american embassy
pleading for a way out of the country
there were false claims on radio and
social media that the u.s would be
handing out humanitarian visas
haiti has asked the u.s to send troops
to help stabilize the country
but for now washington only plans to
send fbi
and homeland security agents to
investigate the assassination
as travel restrictions ease across the
country more canadian airlines are
returning to the skies
toronto-based porter airlines is the
latest carrier
charting its post pandemic course after
more than a year of being grounded
as ann gaviola explains the airline
industry is poised
for a comeback
porter plans to resume flying on
september 8 to select canadian
destinations including the toronto
island airport ottawa montreal and
thunder bay
adding u.s stops september 17 marking an
end to a dry spell of nearly a year and
a half the company's plans to take to
the skies have been pushed back 11 times
during the pandemic
but the ceo says he's confident about
the latest plan porter is
relaunching service september 8th which
we're thrilled about
and we'll be adding flights throughout
september and into early october
and we'll have our entire route network
of year-round destinations up and
running prior to canadian thanksgiving
there will be heightened safety measures
and that means extra training the
carrier has called back about 500
employees with plans to increase staff
as flights are added
i got sort of anxious at times to see
if and when this day would happen dave
robson has worked for porter for eight
years he's looking forward to seeing his
colleagues and passengers
in person we've had a few changes and
dates
and when i actually opened my email and
saw that
it's official i was very excited and
highly optimistic
porter secured 270 million dollars worth
of loans from the federal government
last week and
20 million of that is earmarked for
passenger refunds
now passenger refunds are being offered
as well as travel vouchers with a
premium of 25 percent
for flights that were canceled between
february 2020 and monday
and for new flights there are refunds
being offered regardless of ticket type
until late december starting this week
fully vaccinated canadians and permanent
residents who test negative for covid
don't have to quarantine for 14 days
this comes as restrictions ease across
the country
this week air canada announced the
resumption of 17 international routes
westjet is adding domestic destinations
this summer and low-cost carrier flare
airlines is adding u.s routes in the
fall
we've seen a very robust recovery in the
u.s mexico has actually got a very
robust
recovery underway as well which i think
bodes well
for a strong recovery for canadian
airlines
but we're not out of the woods yet the
border with the u.s remains closed to
non-essential travel
and although analysts predict a spike in
demand as people rush to visit friends
and family this summer
they see a dip in the fall as workers
return to the office business travel
isn't expected to bounce back until next
year
we've had an enormous response from
passengers you know that are excited to
move again we'll we'd be back at 100 on
day one
absolutely not but we do see a fairly
you know rapid recovery of traffic once
it's safe to fly again
ann gaviola global news toronto
up next cooking up culture the menu for
a top chef
and his young apprentice
an indigenous teenager is embarking on a
culinary journey
the aspiring cook has a lot to learn and
he has a lot to teach
as shelly steeds explains he wants to
serve up indigenous culture
what we're using is some tarragon right
caleb francis has been dreaming of this
moment since he was a little boy
growing up and elsie book took first
nation cooking for his family
i'm hoping to learn different cooking
techniques and different
different ways of cooking at only 14
years old
caleb has been hired by red seal chef
gene cormier
to work at his restaurant at parley
beach in sheddiac excellent
his youngest apprentice to date caleb is
honing his culinary skills
and working toward his dream to one day
open his own restaurant
where he hopes to delve more deeply into
his traditional
culinary culture when i start getting
older i want to start doing like trips
to different
reserves and finding out more about the
traditional cooking and
introduce that into my life so it can be
shared
with others it's something as dear to
his heart as cooking
i think it's important because a lot of
our language was like taken away a lot
of our culture
was like taken so i want to
introduce that back into like the world
you want to try to bunch it all together
gene looks forward to helping caleb
master his culinary techniques
and help him work toward his dreams it's
for caleb to express
himself from a culinary standpoint to
put flavors on a plate
and to showcase what represents him
nancy millier runs the youth cultural
center in elsi book took
she would like to see more employers
reach out to the indigenous community
give us opportunities for our youth to
grow
that we may not have in our own
community that we could give to them
caleb will work here for the next few
summers
developing his culinary skills and he
plans to study culinary arts after
graduation
seeing that the potential and the growth
that this kid's going to see in the next
couple years if this is what he's going
to be anchored in is going to be amazing
shelly steves global news shediac
and that is global national for this
saturday night i'm robin gill tonight
your canada
is sydney nova scotia thank you for
watching have a great night
[Music]
you